thank you very much and yeah it's true I
been trying to tell
you I have this book out there if you'll
pardon the uh advertisement I have a new
book out that I was going to talk about
but you'll just have to buy it um I have
an old book the Palestinian delusion the
catastrophic history of the Middle East
peace process which is also out there
and you will find in there everything
that elucidates the conflict at hand and
actually I uh took a few notes this
morning that are from that book to
explain what we're dealing with these
days so I wanted to give you a
quote this is a uh quote I'll tell you
who said it after I read it no longer
are we
necessarily A people who dwells alone
and no longer is it true that the whole
world is against
us we must overcome the sense of
isolation that has held Us in its thrall
for almost half a century we must join
the international movement towards peace
reconciliation and cooperation that is
spreading all over the entire Globe
these days lest we be the last to remain
all alone at the station who said
it close Yak Robins said it the the
prime minister of Israel in
1992 as he was about to conclude the
Oslo Accords with yaser
Arafat now I submit that that is a quote
a statement that is diametrically
opposed to the spirit of another prime
minister of Israel as a matter of fact
Yak Robins predecessor in his first term
as prime minister golden Mayer Who said
very famously if we have a choice
between being dead and pied and being
alive with a bad image we'd rather be
alive and have the bad
image
now what Yak Robin was saying and what
happened at
the Oslo Accords was exactly the
opposite it was opting to be dead and
pied essentially but what he was doing
was obviously not that explicitly he was
saying we have to join the International
Community and not be isolated anymore
and join the international movement
towards peace now what is the fallacy in
what he was saying it is that it was not
because of Israel's actions that Israel
was isolated and not part of the
international movement towards
peace what we have are fundamentally
opposed views of the world that cannot
possibly be reconciled and one of them
is the idea that the world is moving in
progressing in a positive direction and
that it's kind of an inevitable
progression which is a Marxist idea
toward a wonderful culmination of a uh
society that is completely at peace and
Equitable and just and that's the
Marxist idea you have to spill a lot of
blood to get there but ultimately you
get to the dictatorship of the
proletariat and then the state Fades
away and there's true communism and
everything is okay now if you believe
that then you believe that you can sit
down with anyone and settle your
problems but then you come up against
people who believe in something else and
so I give you a quotation from the Quran
the holy book of Islam which speaks
about Abraham and you might think isn't
that nice that it speaks about Abraham
see we're all abrahamic faiths Judaism
Christianity and Islam and we all have
Abraham in common he is our common
father and we are all his children and
we can build bridges on that basis and
if you think that sounds fatuous you're
right except that's what George W bush
said and Barack Obama and uh certainly
Joe Biden in his more Lucid moment
moments and there is no dissenting voice
essentially from the idea that we can
build the same kind of common ground
that yak Rabin was talking
about on the basis of the shared common
the the shared areas of our three
religious faiths however when you look
at Abraham in the Quran it tells you in
chap 3: 67 that Abraham was neither a
Jew nor a Christian Abraham was a
Muslim now you might wonder how is it
that Abraham could be a Muslim when
Abraham lived hundreds and hundreds of
years before
Muhammad well the Islamic scheme in the
Islamic understanding the original
religion of all the prophets was
Islam Abraham taught Islam Moses taught
Islam they were all Muslims John the
Baptist taught Islam Jesus taught Islam
every last one of them was a Muslim and
then what happened they had bad
followers and their bad followers
twisted their teachings to create what
we know of as Judaism and
Christianity so they are false Twisted
hijacked versions of the original
Islamic teachings of the prophets so
while the judeo-christian tradition is
full of leaders who will say we have
this wonderful abrahamic Faith com
commonality the vision of Abraham in
Islam is rejectionist in an absolute
sense and that is we are the true
children of Abraham and you all are
not and what does that mean in practice
is another passage chapter
60:4 and it has Abraham telling his
father because remember Abraham's a
Muslim and his father is not his father
is a polytheist and so Abraham says
there has arisen hostility
and hatred between us forever until you
believe in Allah
alone so there has arisen hostility and
hatred between us forever until you
believe in Allah alone think about that
and compare that to we must join the
international movement towards
peace how are you going to do that when
you have some people who think there is
hostility and hatred between us forever
because you do not share
the religion that I
do that I have and so the fundamental
mistake of all of the policy of Israel
toward its own defense and the United
States in Alliance with Israel since the
1970s has been to Discount even the
possibility that there could be people
in the world who actually think that
there is an insurmountable hostility and
hatred
that there is a hostility and hatred
that is divinely commanded that cannot
ever be
ended because it comes from God and so
there is absolutely no way you can sit
down at a table and come to some kind of
reconciliation peace and
cooperation that will allow both groups
to live in
peace you have hostility and hatred
forever now now what is the chief State
aside from Hamas and hisbah and
Palestinian Islamic Jihad and all the
rest of them what is the main state that
is against Israel
today Iran now that in itself ought to
give you the understanding right away
that all the analysis you hear about
this conflict from the state department
and from the United Nations and from
everybody else on the planet except
me is wrong is the fact that Iran is
Israel's Chief enemy why because look on
a
map how does Israel threaten
Iran why on Earth would
Iran which has been where it is for
thousands of years and does not have a
border with
Israel how is it threatened by this tiny
Jewish state that is several Nations
away you got you got Syria and you've
got Jordan and you've got
Lebanon in between essentially kind of
in between in the
neighborhood
so why on Earth does Iran have such
hostility and hatred towards
Israel because Iran is an Islamic
Republic when Iran was not an Islamic
Republic it was not hostile towards
Israel when Islam and Iran was ruled by
the Sha the
ayatollahi was trying to overthrow the
Sha in the 1960s and70s and the
Ayatollah Ki said an interesting thing
he said Israel does not want the Quran
to be in this country Israel does not
want the rules of Islam to be in this
country now this is insane but think
about it try to understand what on Earth
is going on here why would CI blame
Israel when he's got the Sha right there
who has westernized his country and
secularized it and deemphasized Islam
and the Quran why would Ki reach out and
say it's Israel's
fault because the Sha for whatever else
he was was still a Muslim so he was a
bad Muslim he was an apostate or a
hypocrite or whatever you want to call
him but he was still within the fold
whereas Israel they know there is
hostility and hatred between them
forever and so if there is a country
that is trying to destroy
Islam in Iran well it's got to be Israel
because after all there's another
passage of the Quran chapter 5: 82 which
says that you will find that those who
have the greatest hatred for you are the
Jews in other words the Jews are
specified in the Quran as the foremost
enemies of the Muslims so I to trying to
figure out what happened to my wonderful
Islamic Iran why is it not Islamic
anymore oh it's Israel's fault well who
else they're the worst enemies of the
Muslims there's hostility and hatred
between them and the Muslim
forever and so that's that as far as
he's
concerned that is enough for it to be
for Israel to be responsible for the
Sha's regime and then for Israel to
become the foremost enemy of K's
regime it all has to do with Islam there
is no other explanation for it you
cannot say well Israel stole Iran's land
well Israel has colonized and oppressed
Iran Israel has has done this or that no
the only reason why Iran cares about
what's happening or allegedly happening
with the Palestinians is because of
Islam because of the solidarity of the
Islamic umah the worldwide Islamic
community now this is extremely
dangerous also
because Iran is a Shiite State there are
sunnis and there are
Shiites the sunnis are about 85 to 90%
of the Muslims in the world the sh ites
are
Iran and Bahrain which Iran claims as
the 15th province of
Iran and Iraq which is 55%
Shiite and then there's 10% Shiites in
Saudi Arabia and Shiites in
Lebanon but primarily you have Iran in a
world of sunnis that is essentially
hostile to it but the the Iranians have
Ambitions they would like to overcome
the sunnis and become the leaders of the
Islamic
world and how could they do that when
they're so vastly outnumbered well
they're they're working on
it they have Iraq now which as I said
has a Shiite majority for years the
Syrian regime was a client state of Iran
now that's a little bit in flux the
Assad regime is alawite alawites are an
offshoot of Shiite Islam
the Iranians are 12 or Shiites that's
the main form of Shiites but they are a
lot of different Shiites and the
alawites are a Shiite group that is
about 12% of Syria but they rule the
country and they are propped up by the
support from Iran although the relations
have been straining lately then you have
his Bala in Lebanon which is a wholly
owned and operated subsidiary of the
Islamic Republic of Iran and then you
have Hamas and Palestinian Islamic Jihad
that are Sunni that Iran is
funding and if you look at a map you're
getting to have this entire a kind of
Crescent as it were of Shiite
hegemony that could result in the
Shiites if they destroy Israel which of
course they want to do becoming the
foremost Islamic power in the world far
surpassing all the Sunni States and
overcoming any Challenge from Egypt or
Saudi Arabia or turkey to be the leader
of the Islamic world because they're the
ones who destroyed
Israel and when they're playing this
game it's very dangerous because of
Shiite
theology Shiite theology is a Theology
of loss and defeat paradoxically enough
because the Shiites were always a
minority in Islam and in Islam you got a
problem
kill you got a
dispute kill you got a a domestic
argument hit
her violence is the key to the whole
thing you you have a problem you solve
it by violence terror is the key to the
whole thing you have a death penalty for
apostasy you have a the the wife beating
that I just mentioned you have the uh
amputation for theft stoning for
adultery all these different penalties
that are designed to terrify people into
staying in line the whole core of Islam
is Terror it's not just a it's not a bug
it's a feature it's it's core to the
thing itself like you could say
Christianity is a religion of love if
that is true Islam is a religion of
Terror it's not just about the terrorism
the whole thing is based on fear that
you get too frightened to
disobey now the problem with that that
is that when the Shia are living with
the sunnis they are getting killed quite
a bit and the Shia idea is that there
were that that in the first place that
Muhammad appointed Ali IB ABI Talib who
was his son-in-law to be his
successor and the sunnis say no he
didn't and that the leader of the Muslim
Community has to be a descendant of Ali
IB and Ali ABI Talib so there were 12 of
those and they were known as the
imams in Sunni Islam the Imam is like
your local Parish priest or Rabbi or
whatever but in Shiite Islam the Imam is
the infallible guide of the community
and the successor of Ali and
Muhammad and so the successor of Ali and
Muhammad most of them were killed by the
sunnis and then in the year
869 this 5-year-old kid became the Imam
because it was a hereditary thing you
have to be in Ali's household
so in
874 he
disappeared he was probably murdered by
the sunnis but nobody knows he vanished
and the
Shiite idea is that he's still
alive he could be here
and he's
hiding until the day when the Muslims
are persecuted more fiercely than they
have ever been persecuted before and
then he will
reappear and this is something that is
fervently believed by the hierarchy of
the Islamic Republic of
Iran now what if you have this idea and
when he by the way when when he comes
back he's going to save everything he's
the Savior figure the 12th Imam the
hidden Imam he's going to just wait you
know when he gets here you're all going
to get it and then the world will be at
peace cuz everybody will be dead or
Shiite
so they're waiting for this consummation
of all things that's going to come from
this 5-year-old who's going to come
back and lay
waste and establish the victory of the
Shiites but he's only going to come back
when you are in a persecution that is
more severe than you have ever endured
before you the Muslims so what could
that
be a nuclear strike what if for
example the Islamic Republic of Iran
sends nukes to Israel and Israel
retaliates the president of Iran from
1989 to 97 Ali Akbar Hashmi rashan Jani
he said application of a nuclear bomb
would not leave anything in Israel but
the same thing would just produce
damages in the Muslim World in other
words we can take this we don't
care how could he say that he he
wouldn't mind it would just produce
damage damage he's talking about 10 to
15 million people dead in Iran how how
could he say oh that's okay we could
endure that because that would bring the
G the kid
back the 12th imom would return because
the Muslims are so
persecuted mmud aad the former president
of another former president of Iran used
to go to this
well where the hidden Imam was hiding
and he would talk to
him and I say that to tell you how
seriously this is all taken
it may sound crazy but this is believed
very fervently by the people who are in
charge in
Iran and
so if they send a nuclear bomb to
Israel then what they Envision is that
Israel will be destroyed Iran will be
victorious the sunny States will have to
accept the hegemony of Iran over the
world over the Islamic world and then
they will be able to proceed to wait
Jihad against the rest of the world in
order to bring it under the hegemony of
Islam as
well because ultimately this is a
maximalist vision I expect you are
likely are aware of that but I'll just
make sure chapter 8:39 of the Quran says
fight them until persecution is no more
and the religion is all for
Allah so see if you fight them until
persecution is no more well that's not
so bad then if we just stop persecuting
them then everything will be okay but
then there's the second part of the
passage and religion is all for Allah so
if there's any religion that's not for
Allah in the world they got to keep
fighting and so this is the fundamental
fallacy in what Yak Rabin said
that we must join the international
movement towards peace reconciliation
and cooperation that is spreading all
over the entire Globe these days ain't
it wasn't then and it isn't now there
was never a movement for peace
reconciliation and cooperation in the
Islamic world it was always about
subjugation
submission and the Islamic
hemony and this brings us to the even
larger
picture that what we have here is a
enormous
struggle between
collectivism and the Dignity of the
individual
collectivism is Marxist as well as
Islamic in Islam this is why they love
each other in
Islam you have to join the umah and the
rights of the umah are much more
important than your individual life we
see this all the time I have stories at
Jihad watch on this practically every
day Brothers kill sister for not wearing
hijab now how could they do that how
could they value her adherence to Islam
more than her life
itself such that her life is absolutely
worthless if she doesn't adhere to Islam
because it's all about the
collective you're either in the Islamic
group or you're absolutely
worthless and your life is
forfeit you have to conform to all and
and people have often noted that there's
a great deal of hypocrisy y in the
Islamic world because of the death
penalty for apostasy and because of the
stifling social order there's a lot that
goes on behind closed doors particularly
in Iran you know there's a whole culture
that people have written about in the
west from time to time of young people
in particular of course and they're
wearing the hijabs and they go to the
mosque and they say their prayers and
then they go to uh uh somebody's
apartment and they turn out all the
lights and they lock all the doors and
then comes the tequila and the dancing
and the hijabs go off and then if the
part's over and the hijab goes back on
and they go back out to the
mosque now this is the idea really that
all you have to do
is adhere to the collective which they
do and you don't have to go along with
it in your head in your heart in your
mind you just have to
submit and Marxism is much the same way
Marx the marxists don't really care if
we believe that Joe Biden is really the
president or something like that we just
have to go along and not make waves
about it they don't really care if we
believe that this vaccine is going to
cure us of this uh this this virus or
not we just have to get it to show our
submission
both Marxism and Islam are all about the
collective and submission to the
collective and so they have this
magnificent
Alliance and I'll conclude just by
saying that there is hope amid all this
because of the uh cracks in the alliance
and they are in the first place the
difficulties between the Sunni and the
Shia
that Iran has this wonderful plan to
destroy Israel and become the leader of
the Islamic World while turkey and Egypt
and Saudi Arabia do have a lot to say
about that and then as I noted yesterday
if you were around the uh biggest foes
right now on the ground at the
Grassroots level of the lgbtq madness
are Muslim groups when they've been
allies all this time and uh as I said
yester yday don't be fooled by this into
thinking oh now we can be Pals and there
will be a wonderful Coalition of social
conservatives with the Muslims and the
uh conservative Jews and Christians
remember hostility and hatred between us
forever I didn't say it it's in the holy
book of Islam thank you very
[Applause]
[Music]
much
so questions comments death bot
was Robert I'm going to give Nina the
mic
Nina hi Mike thank you um well okay now
you're Israel and um uh what what do you
do to hold Iran accountable that isn't
going to be
counterproductive hold what do you do to
hold Iran accountable yeah I
meanig stri oh no certainly not the
problem the difficulty is that if you
strike Iran directly then you have the
possibility of very real possibility of
a world war with Russia getting involved
China getting involved and then the
United States getting involved I don't
know on which side really but um in any
case I think that uh the best that
Israel can do right now is what it has
been doing and that is all the
mysterious computer failures at the
nuclear plants the mysterious deaths of
the nuclear scientists things like that
to hamstring Iran's ability to uh make
the war against Israel but unfortunately
the the coraly of golden Mayer's
statement that it's better to be alive
and hated than dead and pied is that
Israel is alive and hated is very
isolated is very little room to maneuver
as a result but clandestine operations
under the table operations against Iran
are going on it does it appear to be the
case and that's all together to be
applauded Robert right here uh yeah two
quick questions one uh would you uh care
to venture the role of Pakistan in the
Islamic uh puzzle of course they're
mortal enemies with India India has a
lot to say China
the the Muslims if they think they're
going to take care of the world or
dominate they have two big problems
China and
India and they knew not to fool around
with the
Mongols they didn't try to go that far
east and so they got a big problem if
they want to go that way and the one
statement I'll make is I think China
will put the brakes on Iran cuz China
doesn't want to go to war with the
United States right now if Iran pushes
this to the point china has to get
involved we may have to respond and if
we respond we have to go with the
knockout punch and that's nuclear war
yes and they don't want it because why
would you want to go to war with the
United States if you know the United
States is
imploding I think it's actually
unfortunately it's a great time to go to
war with the United States because what
are the troops going to do hit them with
their purse but anyway
um the question about
China it's very complicated because
China is working to create a web of
alliances with the Belton Road
initiative all across Asia and that is
primarily focused on
Pakistan with uh
interesting things going on the
pakistanis are kind of the shock troops
of the Islamic world they're they're
they're not Arabs and so they're very
anxious to prove how Islamic they are
even though they're not Arabs uh non
non-arabic Muslims tend to have kind of
an inferiority complex because Islam is
so Arab supremacist you know every every
convert to Islam changes his name to
some Arab name as if he's from Mo Riad
or something but anyway uh you remember
muham mad Ali but
uh
the
pakistanis even though they are so
fervent against uh India and they are
working hard to destroy India you have
the isi the Pakistani intelligence
service kind of the Pakistani CIA
actively working with Jihad groups in
India and they were behind the 2008
Mumbai bombings and ver and other
attacks and they are trying to undermine
India and create an Islamic State but
China is putting the breakes on that as
you noted uh there was a Chinese uh
engineer working in Pakistan on this
Belton Road initiative and he was
complaining during Ramadan you guys
can't you can't you have something to
eat and get some work done and he was
arrested and and and charged with
blasphemy and he was going to be put to
death and and the Chinese government uh
called up made a few calls and he was
fine and so China is indeed putting the
breaks on this at this point at the same
time we don't know when they are going
to think it is opportune to hit the
United States it's probably a matter of
when and not if and so they are building
alliances with Islamic countries in
Central Asia and ultimately we're going
to be seeing the results of
that oh Evelyn
I no I got the
mic um I Heard U an IDF spokesman say
about a week ago that um what Hamas has
done is against Islam yeah um does he
say that not you know for for tactical
reasons not to upset or get more uproar
in the on the West Bank or so or is it
um
or or they they don't just don't get it
what do you think I don't really know
whether the IDF knows or not uh it may
be that they are thinking if we say this
then there will be some Muslims who will
not fight and be on our side in which
case they're
naive uh or it may be that they really
do think that it's against Islam in
which case they're worse than naive the
fundamental question is over
civilians that uh h of course killed
women and children and Muhammad
expressly forbade the killing of women
and
children however there is another
tradition in the uh large body of
traditions about Muhammad in which uh
the Muslims are bombarding or
catapulting uh stones into this
fortified town and some people come to
him and say you know that there are
women and children in there with the
polytheists and Muhammad says oh they're
from them they're they're they're in
other words they are with those people
they're all the same so it doesn't
matter and so in one case he says don't
kill women and children and in another
he says oh it doesn't matter and so that
that's the problem with Islamic
tradition it's full of contradictions
because it's really all
fiction and it's there there there was
no Muhammad he didn't say anything and
when the Muhammad myth started to be
constructed he is made to say whatever
faction wants him to say to support
their own position so when you have two
different factions with differing views
then he says both things and that's all
through Islamic tradition but this is
one of the foremost instances of it
where he disapproves of killing
civilians and then approves it and
generally uh Islamic authorities like
zahawi the former head of al-Qaeda in
Iraq way back in like 2005 or 6 he
justified the killing of civilians by
Al-Qaeda on the basis of the fact that
the they were essentially collateral
damage that they were not being aimed at
uh now of course you could say in Israel
well they were being targeted they you
know you have people paragliding into a
music festival and killing people who
were having a good time there and that
you can justify by the of repeated
rhetoric about how there are no
civilians in Israel they're all
combatants because are on this stolen
land and the land belongs to Islam etc
etc etc in other words there are endless
justifications for this in Islam and
it's IR responsible of the IDF either to
not know or to dissemble about that fact
there are indeed arguments that say that
it's against Islam but we're not really
seeing any Muslims standing up now and
saying it's against Islam are we we're
only seeing demonstrations in favor of
Hamas all over the world and uh Nar a
one saying GE that's terrible you
shouldn't have done that it's against
Islam in every case like this it's
always the non-muslims saying it's
against Islam we should instead listen
to what they're
saying yes um I have a
question with the current
Administration do you feel that the
level of
infiltration uh of jihadists or even
just Muslims is having an effect uh and
and a continuing effect on the US
pulling the leash back on Israel in
their attempts to defend their country
over and over again very much so the
Biden as a matter of fact old Joe just
met a couple days ago with M Gage which
is a Muslim Brotherhood organization
that he met with in
2020 and he promised them that they he
would appoint Muslims at every level of
his administration and one of the
Muslims he appointed was Hadar who was
the chief Chief
negotiator that is when there were
Israeli Palestinian negotiations about
anything and the US Representative is
there it's this guy who is a Palestinian
pro- Jihad
activist and so that just shows you in
itself and he's not by no means the only
one that the people who are guiding the
regime policy the Biden regime policy on
Israel are all pro- Jihad and pro Hamas
thank you and that is a uh deliberate
strategy I mean of course this is a
Marxist regime that is uh
inherently Allied as I explained with
the Islamic forces worldwide and so this
has been a deliberate
strategy Robert what do we know about um
Robert Mali uh and um what do you think
is the appropriate thing to be done yeah
you know Robert M is quite a case if you
haven't heard of him he he is a longtime
Washington Insider an Obama Biden uh key
player who was actually dismissed from
the Obama Administration for being too
Pro
Hamas so then after the media Firestorm
died down he was hired
back because the Obama Administration
and the Biden regime are both Pro Hamas
so Robert became Biden's Chief
negotiator for the Iran deal because of
course Trump repudiated the Obama Iran
deal Biden wanted to repudiate Trump so
he wanted to restore the Iran deal but
the Iranians ultimately it proved
impossible because they had this
Uprising Nationwide in their own country
and it would have looked too bad for
Biden to conclude a deal with Iran while
those uprisings were going on and the
whole thing ran off the rails but the
story of that it's really disgraceful
and Robert Mali was primarily
responsible Robert
Mali understood actually the Iranians
made it clear that they would not
negotiate with the Americans because
we're so evil the great Satan and all
that and so they said we'll we'll we'll
conduct negotiations but you have to
appoint an
intermediary who did the Biden regime
and Robert Mali appoint as an
mediary
Russia we're fighting this proxy war
against Russia in Ukraine and Russia is
supposed to be defending our interests
in making a deal with the Islamic
Republic of Iran how can how incredibly
absurd is this going to get if I wrote
tried to write a novel and I wrote this
you would say oh no that's unbelievable
that's they couldn't be that stupid well
they're not that stupid they're evil so
Robert Mali has the Russians make the
deal and the deal was done it was all
but agreed to they just couldn't make
the final step because of the
intervening act crisis within Iran but
when the deal was done the Russian
negotiator made an interview and he said
this deal is great and it's very
favorable for the People's Republic of
China and the Islamic Republic of
Iran who did he leave
out yeah so then Robert Mali was
dismissed last summer and it said he was
mishandling classified information and
then gradually the story began to
trickle out Robert Mali was dealing with
a nest of Iranian spies embedded at high
levels within the Biden
regime and many of those spies are still
in place I kid you not uh I can't
remember her name but there is a
highlevel official
chief of staff at the Pentagon thank you
and there is it's documented that she
was calling up people in ton to ask for
advice on how to guide American policy
and she's still on the job what's her
name do you remember her name
AR Aran tabatabai thank you yes that's
it Arion good morning
and there are many others who are still
in places as well so you
know this is a a a comedy it's it's just
incredible this is an absurd thing we
are G governed by a gang of traitors and
it's increasingly obvious and they don't
even care they they they they don't they
don't seem to care that we know maybe
they want us to know because they think
it will be demoralizing and so above all
we must not be demoralized and be more
ever more energized to fight well just a
curious osity I was wondering if this
spy uh the lady is is she uh friendly
with Valerie jerett by any chance I I
don't know but I wouldn't be surprised
of course you know we don't really know
who's running the regime we know it's
not Joe and we know that Barack Obama
told Steven colar in 2021 2017 I think
it was that he would love to have a
third term on the sly in the basement
and his sweats talking to the president
through an earpiece and I think well has
anybody checked Joe's
ear uh maybe that would explain it but
it might not then you got to wonder
who's running Obama because it never
seemed like he was really in charge
either he played a lot of golf in those
days and so you got Valerie Jarrett you
got Susan Rice who knows who else we
don't really know it's all so shadowy I
think we have time for one more question
before we take a
break y okay oh not a question not a
question just a comment I think I
mentioned Mr Spencer the other day when
Churchill's Churchill's comment about
all this kind of summed it up when he
was reviewing the Treaty of Versailles
oh yeah maybe do you remember what he
said uh you you should say it words I'll
I'll say it he he had just reviewed the
Treaty of versailes and he somebody
wanted him to comment it I don't know
the circumstance and he said yeah he
said I think it's a sad and complicated
idiocy that's it that's the the if I
ever write a history of our times it'll
be called a sad and complicated
idiocy thank
you